more good news in the fight against
coronavirus this time from the uk
after 99 of volunteers given the oxford
astrozenica vaccine
developed antibodies to covert 19. these
are the results from the phase 2 trials
using 560 volunteers
results from the larger phase 3 trials
will be published in the next few weeks
but the powerful immune response it's
generating in adults over 60 is
particularly promising
as typically vaccines don't work as well
in older people
the editor of the scientific journal
that reviewed the data
says this vaccine is different to those
produced by moderna
and pfizer bioentech those vaccines are
based on
a technology called mrna
this vaccine is different because
the spike protein which is what provokes
the immune response
is bound to a recombinant adenoviral
vector it's a it's a virus which can
facilitate entry of the spike protein
into
the human cell the oxford vaccine had
been a front-runner in the global race
but was
overtaken by rivals moderna and pfizer
their phase 3 trials show more than 90
percent effectiveness
and they're now pressing ahead with
distribution plans
we have of course to wait uh to wait uh
um
for for authorization and approval yeah
if if everything goes well we could
start to
to to supply the vaccines to europe and
united states in the second half of
december
and and you can see that of course as a
christmas present
even once approved there will be huge
challenges in manufacturing and supply
chains
pfizer's vaccine needs to be stored at
-75 degrees celsius
which could hamper distribution
meanwhile countries are scrambling to
sign contracts
to secure doses for their population
china's synovac is already arriving in
brazil
the country hit hard by coronavirus is
importing some 46 million doses
to be used if it is approved charlie
andra aljazeera